now if we're looking back at our mock
here we're gonna start saying well there
are some things that aren't the same
bootstrap isn't making using this nice
font here there's not light gray what
we've done so far is we've gone through
and we've done what bootstrap can do
natively now what we're gonna do is
we're gonna apply our own styles on top
of that and make the page look a little
a little nicer okay so one of the first
things that we'll notice is that the
font that we have in the mock here is
not the same as the font that we're
getting sort of by default one of the
great things that Google provides is
google fonts so I've found a font that
is similar to the one that we have in
the mock it's not perfect but it'll do
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
select we have a very thin version of it
up here in the in the name and a sort of
thicker higher weight version of it in
the rest of the page so what we need is
two font weights font weights are how
thick or thin a font is and for this
project I'm gonna be using the thin and
the light for those two situations that
just pointed out google fonts may look
slightly different when you use it they
change it from time to time but the
general concept is you're gonna select
your font in this case I've picked lato
motto and we're going to then select
what weight we want to use the
characters in this case we're just going
to use the latin character set if
usually extended if you need accents and
things like that that aren't in the
normal Latin set and we come down here
and Google will have provided us with a
handy little piece of HTML that will
link this font with these weights into
our page so we go back and we're going
to put that up in the in the head and
that will make sure that we have that
font loaded and ready to go but just
loading it into the page isn't going to
do anything we actually have to
make a style that can use it and that
tells our page to use it so what we're
gonna do next is that we're basically
just going to make a style CSS and this
will contain all of our personal styles
so we've used bootstrap styles already
and we'll make our own style CSS so in
the same way that we loaded bootstrap in
we're going to load in our own styles
and we're gonna put them below bootstrap
remember that CSS is applied in the
order that it shows up all things being
equal so if we want to have our Styles
not be overwritten by similar styles in
bootstrap we're gonna put our Styles
last in this list so in our Styles CSS
we're gonna add a body selector so this
will target the whole HTML body and what
we're gonna do then is if we go back to
Google Fonts they'll actually have
provided how to integrate it into our
CSS so it'll give us this font family
and we're gonna put that right into our
CSS and that's gonna say to the browser
use this font if possible if not fall
back to it just a whatever since our
font you have flying around so now if we
go back to our page and refresh there we
go so now we're now we're using that new
font we're starting to look a little bit
better a little bit closer to our to our
mock and we can go on from there one of
the things looking at the mock is that
we have some other colors in here it
looks like instead of being sort of the
dark grey or black that is the default
in bootstrap our designer has given us a
color for for all of the text on this
page so we're going to go back we're
gonna add that to the body as well now
this is just the default color we can
overwrite it at any time but this is in
general the text on our site we're gonna
give this color
one of the other things is it because
I'm loading in these two different
weights the thin and the thick I'm gonna
make sure that my style actually calls
that out and says as the as the default
we're going to use this slightly thick
one the 300 weight and so we'll put that
right back in this in this body tag to
so looking at our at our code here the
colors have now changed to the one we we
just set and we know for sure we're
using the right the right weight looking
at our mock we have a few other texts
sort of effects that that I'm seeing
here one of them is this featured work
is in a muted color and one of them is
that the Jane Doe here at the very top
this title is thinner than than the
other sort of headings that we have on
the page so let's write some rules
that'll that'll help us with that
bootstrap as I mentioned before it has a
whole bunch of text helpers like text
upper case text right those sorts of
things so we're gonna make our own and
we'll just add to that collection
we'll make a text muted
and that'll change the color of any text
we put that on to be a little bit more
muted a little gray wall to make a text
thin
and that'll use that thinner version of
the font that we've that we've also
loaded in just making these classes
isn't going to change the way that the
HTML looks that it that it displays on
our page so now we have to go back to
the HTML and add these classes in where
we where we want them so I'm thinking
we'll put the text in on the name and
let's find that featured work here we go
all right so we reload our page here and
now you can see Jane Doe it is the thin
text that we're looking for and featured
work has turned great so it's coming
along here but we've still got a few
more things to kind of polish up and
we'll start to work on one of them is
that the logo here seems to be off a
little bit and we'd like to give it some
some room on the top and another is that
the name this Jane Doe at this title
sort of super title up here is much
bigger than anything else on the page so
we're gonna try and bump that up in in
size
so again in our HTML let's put in some
classes so that we can actually hook on
to that with our with our CSS and target
the right things so one of the things we
wanted to target was that Jane Doe it
that top heading there so we'll make
this we'll give this like a title super
so this is the the biggest title the
biggest title there is and I is at the
top of the page and the biggest thing we
have and then we also wanted to target
that logo so let's call that so things
are similar title logo so that's the
logo that's in that title space and this
is the super text that's in that okay so
now we have that in HTML let's go stick
some CSS to it it's a general note I
generally organized my CSS files when
I'm on smaller projects like this in
will do like the body first the very
basic that resets those sorts of things
general classes classes that get used a
lot and then more specific classes
further down the down the file and for
small things like this it works it works
great it'll let you know in your head
sort of where to look in the file when
you're looking to change something
so for that super title
let's give it a crank it up to sixty
pixels to start this here and then we'll
target the title logo give it a bit of a
margin and push it down to there so now
when we refresh our page that Jane Doe
it is nice and big the logo is nice and
in line we're starting to look a lot a
lot closer to what what we're going for
in our mock here so as I'm looking at
our mock I've actually noticed something
that I missed the first time and this
happens you you basically go through
your design and you're checking its side
for side with your with your mock or
your image and you'll notice something
that you missed the first time and it's
an iterative process as you do it more
you'll miss fewer things the first pass
through but what I've noticed is that I
don't think that my text at the bottom
of these is centered so we'll actually
jump back in you can see down here on in
the featured work section these are all
left aligned and actually as it turns
out everything in this entire section
here is text centered so what we can do
is add that remember bootstrap had that
text centered class we're going to
actually add it to the parent of all of
these and it'll apply to everything
and there we go so now everything is
that sort of centered text and we're
starting to get closer and closer to how
our mock looks now I'm gonna call it
here for now because this has gone
pretty long but you can keep going you
can say hey this HR this this horizontal
rule here is not thick enough
hey there's not it's not quite as bold
as I wanted on these on these titles you
can keep going and keep going closer and
closer to the mock that you're trying
for at a certain point you'll just have
to call it a day and that's okay getting
a web page should look exactly like the
mock that was done in Photoshop or
wherever it came from is tremendously
hard and very time-consuming for the
last couple percent so getting to a good
place and saying hey this looks good I
feel good about this webpage I think
people can can use it if you're working
with a designer getting their thoughts
on that as well as definitely worthwhile
activity and wrapping it up and saying
okay I think we're I think we're good
here so I'm gonna leave this as it is
for right now and I think we'll so I'm
gonna do that right here and just say
hey we're we're good enough for right
now if we wanted to do more work on it
we absolutely could but we've got a
good-looking website here with a lot of
little puppies and I'm a I'm a happy
camper one of the things we get from
using bootstrap is something like this
where if we look at our website and I've
scaled my browser down to be you know
similar to up to a mobile device we
actually get a nice layout all of our
little featured work has gone into a
line here it's readable and we can
actually see it on a on a mobile device
now we didn't do any work to make this
happen which is really impressive and we
definitely could do a few more things
here to make this look better for our
mobile friends but it's a great starting
place and we didn't we didn't have to
worry about it at all